[Musique]
comment L'Archipel du Goulag ou
Alexandre senitine révéla au monde
l'ampleur du système concentrationnaire
soviétique est-il parvenu jusqu'à nous
voilà maintenant 50 ans c'est ce que
vient de nous raconter à l'instant ce
documentaire réalisé par Jean crépu et
Nicolas Miletic et nous allons revenir
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débad dooG sur le travail
mémoriel effectué autour de l'horreur et
de l'ampleur du Goulag Jean crépu est
avec nous bienvenue Jean crépu bonjour
vous êtes documentariste cela fait 20
ans que je réalise des documentaires que
je cherche à éclairer la complexité du
monde en proposant des récits en images
pour témoigner transmettre voilà ce que
vous avez déclaré dans une récente
interview au magazine Telerama ce film
que nous venons de voir a été réalisé en
2008 et il vous a donné l'envie d'une
suite en quelque sorte avec un document
exclusif cette fois pour notre chaîne
qui s'intitule L'Archipel du Goulag le
courage de la vérité et ce film fera
l'objet d'une autre émission où vous
serez également présent avec nous Jean
crépu Sophie curé est avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes historienne
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université Paris Cité et auteur entre
autres de la grande lueur de l'Est les
Français et l'Union soviétique publié
aux éditions du Seuil et réédité un peu
plus tard bien entendu en poche et cette
fois chez CNRS édition et puis Émilia
coustova est avec nous bienvenue à vous
vous êtes historienne professeur au
Département d'études slaves à
l'Université de Strasbourg spécialiste
d'histoire et de civilisation russe et
soviétique et membre fondateur de
mémorial France mémorial international a
été
dissous officiellement c'était en
décembre 2021 par le régime actuel en en
Russie c'est une association pour dire
les choses rapidement he de défense de
droits de l'homme en Russie en revanche
mémorial France existe toujours oui il a
été créé en fait un peu avant la
dissolution de mémorial Russie mémorial
international on y reviendra à tout à
l'heure il a été créé en 2020 pour
justement soutenir nos amis en Russie
qu'on sentait en danger on les sentait
fragilisés par le durcissement répressif
du régime poutinien personne en revanche
ne s'attendait à que ce durcissement
accélère à tel point et aussi rapidement
et que ça conduise de façon absolument
simul anné d'une part à la dissolution
de mémorial international et puis à une
tragédie tellement plus vaste
l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine et
vous aviez vu juste hein puisque en
effet un an plus tard mémorial
international était officiellement
dissous par le pouvoir russe on en dira
évidemment un mot tout à l'heure Jean
crépu ce documentaire donc tourné en
2008 avec la dernière interview de
jenittin c'était ça le coup de force le
hein de de de ce documentaire c'est vous
qui avez réalisé cette interview en 2007
c'est bien ça oui nous sommes partis à
Moscou en décembre 2007 sans être tout à
fait certain que se jcine serait en
mesure de de répondre à nos questions il
était déjà fragilisé par la maladie et
et il a accepté de nous recevoir et
particulièrement pour évoquer L'Archipel
du Goulag ça lui tenait à cœur de de
Racon à nouveau comment ce qu'il avait
vécu sur ce l'écriture de ce de ce livre
qui bouleversera le 20e siècle et la
manière dont il il a réussi à à écrire
ce livre qui nous est très bien
expliquer dans dans ce film on va on va
revenir dans dans un instant safuré la
question qu'on se pose c'est que
savait-on exactement de de ces goulagues
mis en place dès 1923 et Lénine était
encore vivant à l'époque hein ça soulève
aussi cette cette question puisqu'on a
souvent l'habitude de dire que ça couvre
uniquement la période stalinienne ça
fait l'objet d'un de nombreux débat au
sein d'ailleurs des des des historiens
que savait-on avant la sortie de ce
livre de ces fameux goulag soviétiques
alors je dirait qu'on savait à la fois
tout et qu'on ne voulait pas le savoir
ouais c'est-à-dire que il y a un flux
continu d'information alors sur les
premers camp 10 de concentration puis
les camps de déportation et de travail
que sont le que sont le goulac sur la
répression politique ensuite sur les les
enfermements en hôpital psychiatrique
donc tout ça finalement filtre à
l'extérieur mais en fait les voix qui le
porent ne sont pas entendues parce que
elles sont soit censurées soit
délégitimé par la propagande de Moscou
comme des traîtres comme des gens qui
ont fait défection et ou alors on ne
veut pas tout simplement les entendre
pas mais je crois que vous en parlerez
justement dans la le prochain débat
parce que c'est écornit le mythe de
l'avenir radiux et de l'Union soviétique
alors il y a quand même ce fameux
rapport krutchev 1956 20e
congrès du Parti communiste soviétique
kutchef avait prononcé un discours de 4
heures j'ai retrouvé ce qu'il avait
déclaré parce qu'on dit souvent que ce
discours avait évidemment remis en cause
euh le pouvoir personnel de de
Staline mais il déclarait néanmoins à
propos des crimes de masse Staline
démontra son tolérance son comportement
brutal et abusat de ses pouvoirs il
permit d'employer la terreur de masse
alors que les classes exploiteuses
avaient été liquidé qu'il n'y avait plus
de raison sérieuse pour employer des
mesures exceptionnelles
euh donc on
savait à travers ce rapport notamment
qu'il avait existé ces fameux crimes de
masse et ces fameuses départations des
goulag oui tout à fait alors krutchev
commande un rapport à des historiens
c'est le fameux rapport secret qui est
assez détaillé mais en même temps qui
est loin d'être complet puisque il va
concerner essentiellement quand même les
crimes concernant les les élites les
élites du du parti mais c'est vrai que
ça déclenche ce qu'on a appelé le le
fameux dégel hein tout ce tout se dégèle
on parle on communique et on a aussi
envie de de communiquer de nouveau à
l'étranger pour faire entendre la voix
de l'Union soviétique et donc ça ça
déclenche par exemple hein une première
parution spectaculaire et ce et un
passage secret de manuscrit à l'étranger
avant celui de sol médecine qui est
celui de pasterernac le docteur givago
en 1958 donc c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a
des précédents et officiellement on
ferme les goulagues officiellement et en
1958 ils sont rebaptisés en réalité
colonie de redressement par le travail
et placé cette fois c'est important tout
de même sous la tutelle du ministère de
la Justice qui était pas le cas
évidemment précédemment sous Staline
autrement dit les goulagu ont perduré
sous une certaine forme après la
dstalalisation organisée par Crouch chef
oui alors Émilia custova a beaucoup
enquêté elle elle en parlera mieux que
moi je pense qu'on on peut j'ai pensé un
autre parallèle donc comme vous le
soullignez effectivement on on se
débarrasse du nom trop compromis du
goulag en 58 mais on
ne on ne renonce pas à euh à un système
finalement très punitif à une
législation qui est très punitive et qui
ne vise pas uniquement les crimes
considérés comme politique mais aussi de
façon très large utilise la détention
dans des camps pour punir et ça m'a fait
penser aussi à cette cet autre
changement changement de nom puisque
dans la Russie soviétique on aime
beaucoup changer de nom les symboles ont
une grande importance et c'est ainsi que
en 1953 euh on se débarrasse du
ministère de de la Sécurité d'État
puisquelle est trop compromise euh on
tue d'ailleurs on arrête puis on fusille
berriia euh et son entourage mais un an
plus
tard un ministère du du CE de ce même
type et rétabli sous forme de du KGB
qu'on connaît et qui aura une vie très
longue puisque on a encore son héritier
qui qui est le célèbre FSB dans la
Russie post-soviétique voilà donc c'est
le même mécanisme en fait de qui
consiste à rebaptiser euh reorganiser
mais sans renoncer à la nature
répressive et extrêmement autoritaire du
régime quoi qu'il en soit sous l' cou
chef les choses change pourine c'est
très bien expliqué dans dans le film il
arrivera à publier une journée divant
denisovic en 19 62 qui récit d'une
journée décrit dans qui décrit les
conditions de vie dans les camps d'un
simple Z et voilà ce qu'il vous dit pour
ce qui est de la
suite
j'ai été inondé de centaines de lettres
de centaines je n'exagère absolument pas
même de milliers de lett j'ai mis de
côté les lettres les plus intéressantes
cell qui ét les plus fortes j'ai ent
correspondance avec auteurs je les
rencontré j'ai alors compris que le
destin m'envoyait ce dont j'avais besoin
les matériaux pour écrire l'archipel
sont venus à moi à travers ces
gens alors ce qu'il nous dit là c'est
qu'en réalité l'archipel du goulac est
une somme de mémoire collective
227 zec invisible ont contribué à
L'Archipel du Goulag et c'est là toute
la force de ce livre tout à fait ce
jtine reçoit après la publication d'une
journée d'Ivan denisovic vraiment des
des des milliers de lettres et donc il
se rend compte qu'il y a là un matériau
absolument extraordinaire il va dire
d'ailleurs qu' il sait pas encore tout
de suite comment il va structurer son
récit avec T tous ces témoignages mais
c'est une somme considérable et c'est
vrai que c'est sans doute ce qui fait
aussi de ce livre un livre exceptionnel
euh par cette histoire orale de ces
témoignages qu'il a qu'il a reçu et ça
il il en parlait en disant bon je reçois
tellement de lre je rencontre certains
d'entre eux certaines d'entre elles mais
voilà il est il est submergé de de de
témoignages parce que je reprends ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure finalement
tout le monde savait chez les
Soviétiques mais personne n'en parlait
et et là évidemment c'est c'est toute la
force de l'archipel du goulac
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelques 20
millions de soviétiques qui ont été
déportés dans ces camps leurs enfants
voire même leurs petits enfants toute
cette
transmission c'est ça aussi que
symbolise ce livre non oui tout à fait
c'est la c'est la rupture en fait de de
la peur et du mensonge que sol gétine
c'est un mot qu'il répète plusieurs fois
dans le dans le documentaire he
considère comme un comme un vrai devoir
il n'est pas non plus le le premier mais
c'est vrai que il est le premier à mener
cette enquête clandestine absolument
fantastique hein et puis ensuite donc
cette écriture parce qu'il y a aussi
l'écriture de solgenitsine qui est qui
est extrêmement forte qui explique aussi
l'impact de de cet ouvrage mais euh
cette cette aussi cette ce ce talent
d'organisation qu'on voit très bien
d'ailleurs dans dans dans dans le euh
euh dans le documentaire hein euh pour
euh euh finalement euh comment dire euh
permettre à ces gens courageux euh de
transmettre euh leurs témoignag et ça
euh ça a été je crois aussi profondément
ressenti hein dans dans la société russe
euh par la suite euh parce que c'était
c'était aussi quelque chose de de
nouveau euh et ça a fait peur euh au
pouvoir au pouvoir soviétique hein qui
euh euh la la muselait finalement
rapidement euh oui parce qu'près l'ire
kutchev l'ire la fameuse aire de
glaciation brechnev et là les choses se
compliquent pour sur jitine Oui il est
il est enfin il il le dit d'ailleurs et
puis c'est c'est on le voit bien dans
dans le documentaire hein il est de
nouveau
surveillé empêché de de publier parce
que aussi il y a tout ce contexte russe
et enfin soviétique et international
hein c'est le début de la dissidence euh
ce sont les négociations aussi autour de
des accords d'alsinki la liberté les
droits de l'homme deviennent un enjeu
international et donc solgittin est un
homme finalement de plus en plus
dangereux pour le pouvoir soviétique
vous souhaaitiez rajouter quelque chose
oui c'est vrai que c'est c'est un un un
un passage qu'il faut bien saisir c'est
que au moment de la publication d'une
journée
d'ivanisovic ctil on le voit d'ailleurs
dans les archives du film et reçu au
kremelin il est voilà il
est je dirais tout va bien il peut
travailler voilà à partir du moment o où
krutchev s'en va et que breev arrive là
tout de suite il y a un changement de de
de de nature et ce gicde va être obligé
de travailler effectivement dans la
clandestinité et c'est ça qu'on a voulu
raconter aussi dans ce film cette
organisation absolument incroyable d'un
homme qui avec un réseau va essayer de
constituer voilà une façon de pouvoir
écrire en ne laissant jamais au même
endroit les parti de son manuscrit donc
quelque chose de tout à fait
recambolesque alors que le KGB voilà il
était après étroitement surveillé donc
c'est c'est faut bien comprendre ce
changement entre un seul géncine reçu au
kremelin qui reçoit des lettres de ce ce
livre et puis après la clandestinité et
je pense qu'ussi à ce propos on
pourrait on devrait souligner ce refus
de la part de solgénitine d'occuper une
place que le régime en tout cas celui de
khouo est prêt à lui donner cette place
d'un écrivant autorisé qui peut publier
il n'y a pas que une journée d'Ivan
denisovic qui est publié en 62 63 à
novémir il y a aussi la maison de
matrena qui est aussi très bien reçu et
est une page très importante pour la
littérature russe du de de ce 20e siècle
et donc on lui propose cette place il
comprend très bien les enjeux il
comprend qu'il faudra négocier il faudra
lâcher certaines choses il est prêt à
jusqu'à un certain moment il est prêt
même à lâcher certaines choses par
exemple le le pavillon des cancéreux il
accepte de de changer certaines certains
détails pour voir ce roman paraître mais
ça ne marche pas et puis il y a
effectivement le BR ruchchov est écarté
en octobre
1964 très vite les vis se resserrent et
sogine il rompent à partir de voilà ce
moment-là 64 ou 65 il rompent et euh à
partir de là euh sa position euh
intransigeente à l'égard du gouvernement
soviétique elle va devenir de plus en
plus explicite claire et dite avec un
courage absolument incroyable que ce
soit sa lettre envoyée en
1967 à ses camarades écrivains où il
exige l'abolution de la censure ou
encore euh quelques années plus tard ces
interviews données à des journalistes
étranger c'est vraiment une d'un courage
incroyable oui parce que ce Jenine prend
une dimension
internationale 1970 prix Nobel de
littérature oui on va vooir un autre
extrait he du film cette fois euh euh il
y a 50 ans et nous sommes là pour
commémorer hein ce demi-siècle hein
maintenant après la sortie de de
lachipelle du Goulag décembre 73 toute
fin décembre 73 ce livre est enfin
publié mais il est d'abord publié en
russe
grâce au samisd ce réseau informel où
des lecteurs anonymes prennent le risque
de faire des copies et de diffuser des
livres interdits L'Archipel du Goulag va
passer de main en main dans tout le
[Musique]
pays c'était très dangereux de le lire
on prenait ce livre pour une nuit celui
qui l'avait pris le lisait pendant la
nuit et le rendait le lendemain matin
pour ne plus l'avoir chez lui même si la
nuit on pouvait venir chez vous saisir
ce livre on le lisait en grand secret et
avec peur les Russes vont lire sous le
manteau hein c'est
l'expression parce que évidemment il est
interdit de publication en Union
soviétique tout à fait le livre va
effectivement c'est l'expression qui
convient circuler sous le
manteau il sera lu parle des des des
cuisines de Moscou il sera lu dans dans
ces petits intérieurs d'appartement
voilà c'est vrai que c'est dangereux de
lire ce livre c'est encore plus
dangereux même de le
reproduire déjà le lire c'est c'est
c'est déjà un danger le se mettre à le
reproduire est encore plus dangereux
celui qui l'avait pris le prenait pour
le lire la nuit et le rendait le
lendemain matin pour ne plus l'avoir
chez lui même si la nuit on pouvait
aussi venir chez vous saisir ce livre
qu'il nous a dit dans cet extrait c'est
terrible on a du mal à se rendre compte
aujourd'hui euh de cette époque de d'une
Union soviétique totalement bon et alors
question évidemment pourquoi l'avoir
d'abord publié en russe grâce à un
éditeur présent à à Paris hein
d'ailleurs pourquoi ne pas avoir choisi
d'embler le le le publié dans les autres
langues dont le français ça viendra un
peu plus tard en 74 il vous a donné une
une réponse à cette question alors c'est
c'est pas très clair tout ça c'est vrai
que quand le manuscrit euh est
transformé en microfilm et passe à
l'ouest euh nikitastru va être en charge
le plus vite possible de le de le
traduire de le de le publier en russe
pardon donc Claude Duran s'en
expliquera il se passera un certain
temps avant que la traduction française
soit prête mais c'est vrai que l'idée
c'était de le publier le plus rapidement
possible euh et à partir du moment où C
Jine donne l'ordre de le publ est là on
est en septembre a septembre ou 73 euh
voilà le dispositif nickitastru les
éditionscpress n'était pas non plus une
grande maison d'édition il fallait
réunir les conditions pour mettre en
route cette traduction enfin ce ce cette
publication
et voilà donc tout s fait je dirais un
peu comme ça c'est euh bon alors tout ça
est fait sous le manteau mais ça
n'échappe sans doute pas au KGB à
l'époque quelle est la réaction du du du
pouvoir soviétique après cette
publication du livre en russe et
j'imagine ce constat qu'il est diffusé
dans le pays sous le mteau oui alors le
pouvoir soviétique il était déjà alerté
hein puisque il surveillait non
seulement ce genénitine mais tous ceux
que qu'il a appelé il a il leur a dédi
un livre les invisibles qui sont non
seulement ceux qui l'ont aidé en URSS
mais ceux qui ont passé ces manuscrits
dont nikitastruve et donc ce rôle aussi
de de l'immigration russe et c'est
traducteurs tous ceux qui l'ont en fait
qui se réseau de qui qui a qui lui a
permis de de parler au au plus grand
nombre donc le KGB était tout à fait
tout à fait en alerte et du reste si le
livre a été publié dans La hatâte c'est
que il y a eu cette cet épisode de la
restation d'une des Invisibles son
suicide tragique et donc l'arrestation
de solgitine donc tout était finalement
révélé perdu et il a décidé donc de de
livrer ce manuscrit est-ce que le
pouvoir soviétique a fait une une
pression quelconque par exemple sur la
France pour qu'il soit soit pas publié
en français ou ou sur d'autres pays ça
s'est concrétisé comment cette pression
du du pouvoir soviétique alors le
pouvoir soviétique n'avait pas les
moyens d'exercer de de pression sur
l'édition libre en France en revanche
tout de suite il a déclenché une
campagne dite de propagande ou d'agit
PROE extrêmement impressionnante qui
était tant à destination de l'intérieur
de l'Union soviétique donc se génicine
traînit dans la boue traité de traître
menteur et cetera fabulateur que à
destination des opinions occidentales et
donc j'ai moi-même vu un certain nombre
d'archives du politebreau dans lesquel
l'ambassade donc du RSS en France
raconte comment elle convoque les
dirigeants du Parti communiste français
comment elle inonde la presse française
de de communiquer hein pour essayer de
en fait de juguler le débat qui monte et
d'empêcher une bonne une bonne réception
ce qui ne fonctionnera pas et et on
débattra dans dans l'autre émission sur
la base de votre autre documentaire sur
les déflagrations hein de de ce livre au
sein notamment notamment de la gauche
française et du Parti communiste
français ce livre il sera il sera publié
là ouvertement légalement à la fin de de
l'air gorbachchev c'est bien ça oui
c'est ça c'est en 89 que le livre paraît
en
Russie et c'est un c'est un grand succès
évidemment en tout cas
voilà il été élu à on ne peut pas savoir
à combien il a été élu pense que quand
même étant donné la nature de ce de ce
livre le volume l'ampleur je ne pense
pas que tous les Soviétiques à l'époque
l'ont lu mais en tout cas tout le monde
en a entendu parler ça ça est devenu
vraiment un ouvrage légitime et très
important la preuve d'ailleurs c'est que
le gouvernement soviétique de
gorbachchev a essayé de le faire sien en
quelque sorte et de l'intégrer dans ce
processus de de la révision du passé et
du rapport au passé qui a été enclenché
par la P Stra puisque senitin s'est vu
attribuer le l'un des prix peut-être le
plus prestigieux de l'État soviétique
qui était le prix d'État pour cette
œuvre là en 90 prix qu'il va refuser
puisque il considère justement
que il il ne peut pas s'associer de
cette façon à l'État qu'il juge dès ses
débuts dès 1917 criminel euh voilà après
pourquoi il est en exil il est en exil
al d'abord en Suisse hein je crois puis
surtout aux États-Unis il reviendra en
94 il revient en 94 en Russie pource que
il attend autant de temps finalement
entre la sortie de son livre en Russie
cette fois officielle aux yeux de tous
et ce retour dans le pays euh je pense
qu'il attend de de pouvoir y retourner à
à certaines conditions il ne veut pas
rentrer comme juste un un fils de
pardonné par la patrie il fait un retour
on peut dire triomphal c'est c'est un
retour qui qui qui est mis en scène
puisque donc il arrive par Magadan par
l'extrême orien donc il va traverser
toute la Russie avant
d'arriver à Moscou il va va être
accueilli comme un prophète dans et son
influence sera grande et son prestige
sera extrêmement grand jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à sa mort la preuve c'est que
Poutine après la mort de de sol genitin
va de demander à que L'Archipel du
Goulag soit introduit dans le programme
scolaire russe euh il rest program
terminal je crois terminal exactement il
y reste encore malgré les très récentes
tentatives critiques et tentatives de le
sortir de ce programme là bon reste la
question est-il vraiment lu visiblement
d'après les témoignages des
professeurs pas pas tellement puisque
terminal ça veut dire que tout le monde
prépare son bac et on n' pas le temps de
s'attaquer à cette cette uvre immense
assez difficile d'accès même si elle a
été réduite à un seul volume par la
veuve de sol genittin quel revanche il
avait vécu comme ça à travers les
témoignages qu' vous a livré dans ce qui
était je le rappelle he tout de même la
dernière interview de ce jennyine qui va
mourir quelques mois après que vous
l'ayez rencontré ou oui oui je crois qu'
il tenait particulièrement à reparler de
l'archipel du goulac parce que je pense
que pour lui
euh ce combat qu'il avait mené euh
l'écriture de ce livre dans la
clandestinité tous ces témoignages ce
très long combat qu'il amené euh voilà
c'est c'est c'est là-dessus qu'il
voulait revenir et et quand il a accepté
l'interview c'était vraiment pour parler
de L'Archipel du Goulag comme si euh à
la fin voilà il voulait garder cette
expérience humaine parce que c'est une
aventure humaine absolument incroyable
et et c'est de ça dont il voulait
témoigner alors on arrivit à à
aujourd'hui la présidence Poutine autant
Poutine a a inscrit ce Liv vous l'avez
dit euh euh au programme des terminales
hein en Russie autant euh ensuite hein
Poutine a une faceuse tendance à vouloir
repolitiser l'histoire de l'Union
soviétique quitte peut-être à la
réécrire en glorifiant notamment le rôle
de Staline pendant la euh la Seconde
Guerre mondiale il y a un changement
d'attitude de Poutine à propos de ce que
ce qu' ce qu'on pu être et ce qu' a pu
être la monstruosité ces Goul oui et
puis sans doute aussi par rapport à la
personnalité de ce géncine parce que ça
le renvoie à son propre régime je pense
parce que cette dimension morale cette
dimension humaine elle est très
importante et donc c'est l'idée du du
témoignage courageux quel que soit donc
le prix à payer il y a quand même
évidemment beaucoup d'écho étant donné
que que le système russe actuel devient
de plus en plus répressif donc ça c'est
c'est un point mais il y a aussi je
pense cette relecture du du passé euh
qui est promu ou voir réécrite lui-même
par par Poutine et qui notamment euh bah
on a réhabiliter Staline on réhabilite
on réhabilite Staline ou en tout cas euh
on juste on justifie finalement ces
crimes par la construction la
reconstruction du pays son
industrialisation et euh un point
central la défense contre le nazisme or
dans L'Archipel du Goulag il y a tout un
point dont on ne parle pas assez mais
qui est très important aussi pour sol
génitine qui est dénonciation de la
collaboration euh des euh de certains
soviétiques avec les nazis et son
explication finalement par l'oppression
stalinienne donc tout ce contre-récit ne
va pas du tout euh ne correspond pas du
tout à la glorification de la grande
guerre dite patriotique la Seconde
Guerre mondiale par par Poutine ne lui
convient certainement pas et ça explique
certainement cette cette mise en retrait
hein de de l'œuvre de de solgéicide et
de sa personne avec on l'a dit en début
d'émission la suspension l'arrêt de
mémorial qui a beaucoup contribué à
retravailler à dénombrer les nombres de
victimes de ces euh de de ces goulagues
il existe aujourd'hui semble-t-il hein
ce sont les chiffres dont je dispose ils
datent de 2020 ils sont tirés du
quotidien Lacroix 700 colonies
pénitentiè en Russie concentrant près de
500000 prisonniers politiques je ne sais
pas si vous pouvez confirmer ces
chiffres on ne peut sans doute pas
parler du retour des goulagues néanmoins
on a toujours un système extrêmement
répressif en en Russie ce qui explique
peut-être que Poutine
aujourd'hui cherche à réécrire
l'histoire alors le nombre donc de
détenus enfin ce nombre très élevé
correspond à l'ensemble des détenus
queles que soient les raisons de leur
incarcération et leur
condamnation les prisonniers politiques
sont beaucoup beaucoup moins nombreux
même si leur nombre augmente rapidement
et justement l'une des tâches que
s'attribue l'une des missions que porte
mémorial c'est de euh de de décomter ces
prisonniers politiques et de de
d'essayer de soutenir autant que
possible ces personnes et leur famille
alors euh mais par ailleurs le nombre de
détenus il est très important euh leur
conditions de détention sont extrêmement
difficiles la géographie de cette
détention elle a n'a pas énormément
évolué en tout cas il n'y a pas de
rupture entre la géographie du Goulag et
la géographie du système
pénitentiaire actuel à l'exception
peut-être de quelques grands chantiers
stalinard qui eux ont été enfin les
chantiers pénitentiaires qui eux ont été
abandonnés euh et donc on on retrouve
effectivement des continuités à la fois
pour une
euh un code pénal et tout le système
judiciaire qui vise avant tout de
condamner et de punir plutôt que de de
de juger et peut-être reconnaître l'in
des individus jugés et puis s'y ajoute
depuis quelques années
cette cette justice cette pénalisation
de l'opinion et de toute expression de
de désaccord avec les politiques
gouvernementales c'est ce qui fait toute
l'actualité encore aujourd'hui de ce oui
on a le S de l'archipel du goulac
finalement on a le sentiment
qu'effectivement cette histoire se
poursuit même si effectivement les ne
sont plus les mêmes nous ne sommes plus
dans cette époque de la guerre froide de
l'Union soviétique mais on a le
sentiment que la matrice d'une certaine
façon est toujours à l'œuvre et que la
condamnation récente de Vladimir
caramourza à 25 ans de prison bah nous
en donne un exemple très concret
et et c'est ça qui est un peu terrible
parce que on a le sentiment que ce livre
avait une force et une
puissance et se dire plus jamais ça et
on a malheureusement le sentiment que
cette matrice continue à
fonctionner le travail qu' a effectué
l'association mémoriale internationale
sur le sujet est terminé de fait ou
peut-il encore se poursuivre sur ce
travail mémoriel autour des des victimes
des des goulag non ce travail mémoriel
se poursuit parce qu'il a été
empêché notamment des des fouilles de de
de charnier ont été on été arrêté euh
alors bien sûr on est dans une autre
époque donc les les mais les enjeux
effectivement sont les mêmes les enjeux
de la de l'enquête historique de la
preuve et puis aussi de la circulation
de l'information vers l'extérieur donc
l'époque numérique donne aussi
finalement de la puissance à la
circulation de l'information puisque
mémorial a mis en ligne énormément
d'information mais du point de vue de
l'actualité russe je crois que les
enjeux restent les mêmes hein il faut il
faut témoigner euh et c'est un enjeu à
la fois politique et politique moral et
aussi littéraire parce que l'emprise de
l'État sur sur l'art et sur la création
c'est aussi une une vraie question
Russie ça sera le mot de la fin vraiment
un grand merci hein à tous les trois
avec Jean crépu qui était le réalisateur
de le coréalisateur de de de ce film
d'avoir participé à cette émission des
Badoc il y aura une suite he en quelques
sortte avec un un autre documentaire
vous serez également là pour nous en
parler hein s'intitule l'archipel du
Goulag le courage de la de la vérité
cette fois et on verra avec vous ce
qu'ont été effectivement les les
déflagrations provoquées par la sortie
de ce livre au cœur des années 70 et
plus particulièrement bien entendu au
sein de la gauche française merci à tous
vos réaction ça sera sur hashtag debadog
merci aussi à Selma sali qui m'a aidé
comme elle accoutumé à préparer cette
émission et je vous donne rendez-vous
pour un prochain lesbadoc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à
bientôt
[Musique]